onto lighter stuff that's your question  yeah yeah yeah and we could do that yeah  what do you think I am oh really racist  for a second can I yeah I mean you asked  me  Cambodian wow that's the most advanced  answer I've received in a long time  that that is correct I actually don't  know he's never told me he's right so  I'm actually not sure if that's right or  not yeah what are you I don't it's a fun  meme we don't really say he's never said  oh you've never said but I was not right  no we can eliminate campus or were you  right or were you oh well this this  makes it so it's not racist because I  could have been exactly dead on yeah I  can tell I wasn't though what am I  um Irish  Canadian yes no he's Rich he's very rich  he's very rich oh I very read it yeah  okay let's get that right it doesn't shy  away from that